Hey, that was a good talk, man. Hey,
Gotti.
Uh um I think I'm probably going to take
this a couple of layers down. Uh but
that's all right. Uh so, uh my name is
Max. I work for consortium. Uh we are a
VAR. So, um this is my announcement.
Ivar. I'm new to the VAR space. I
started my career in uh the federal
intelligence community doing cyber crime
investigations. I've been with early
stage startups in cyber. I been big four
um held a few industry roles
practitioner uh and on leadership teams
in industry and I've been varring for
the last five six months or so. Um so uh
one of the things that I focus in in my
dayto-day is um you know it's the
classic matchmaking.
Um our clients come to us with problems
and we try to identify the right
solutions in the marketplace for them.
Uh and I built a tool to help me and my
team do this better um using some of the
tools that we've been talking about. So
um I'll introduce it and then I'll I'll
show the uh the tool in action what that
looks like. Uh, so what is my kind of
regular day-to-day? What does that look
like? Um, I get a call from a client.
They say, "We need some AI security. We
think, um, who do you recommend?" Well,
hold on. Like, that's not enough
information.
What are your use cases?
Um, like what what's your risk tolerance
within the organization? are you
concerned about uh having an incident or
you're more concerned about filing that
incident with the SEC cuz that tells me
two different things.
Uh and they go usually well but who's
good? Just tell me who's good. Um you
know um don't worry about it and hey man
I'm not trying to be annoying. I'm just
trying to bring you know VA back to the
VAR. Um so assuming we have that
conversation and we get a list of
requirements and we understand what the
use case and what the system is being
built and what controls are required.
Uh you know then we start the research.
Um we go and we have some demos with AI
security vendors.
We read their marketing slicks. We look
at their data sheets and we see things
like this.
Swarms of autonomous agents
broadest and most comprehensive.
That's a good one. 99% efficiency at sub
30 millisecond latency.
AI powered thread detection to
automatically block all the adversaries.
So that's like the the dayto-day reality
of Avar.
Um so what we needed to do is you know
have a methodology where we could put
those marketing claims and some of them
may be legit some of them may be you
know the u maybe simple simple PR and
put it through some kind of a framework
through some kind of an assessment
thing. So that's where this thing really
started. um you know we built um
an agent and using clot code
uh ous 4.5 we're at six now obviously um
looking at all of those claims and try
to you know find some substantiating
evidence behind those claims so you know
our clients can make good decisions but
uh you know this started with over 2,000
of those vendor claims that we needed to
make sense of this was in December. I
think we're all well over um 3,000. Um
so when this proposal for the stock was
submitted, uh we've analyzed 62 vendors.
Now we're at nearly 80. Um so this is
just 6 weeks later. Uh roughly, you
know, there's four new startups that
emerge out of stealth that claim to do
AI security or existing cyber security
vendors. bolt-on cyber AI security
features. Um so between those uh you
know it's roughly four new companies
that get added to the database
but assuming that we're able to
translate that into something in some
actionable recommendation
you know still from the VA perspective
the AI governance loop looks something
like this we need AI security
they get six vendor data sheets
um given that there are some
requirements that are known and there's
some discovery that happened prior to
that to uh the team kind of build some
kind of a risk register using some
variation of OASP NISP whatever other
framework um not a ton out there on that
focuses on AI security specifically so
most teams are building this in-house
using spreadsheets and kind of hand
jamming it into their GRC tools
four vendors get invited to demos and
and two of them get a PC invite. PC's
run in parallel. Usually there's not
very clear eval criteria and then PC's
get put on hold because
we're building this thing in AWS's
bedrock. Don't they have guard rails to
do all of this stuff that we're
evaluating the two vendors against?
But wait, uh we have DLP.
They're saying that they can do this.
Can they do this?
And no. By the way, there's a bunch of
open source tools. So, why don't we just
build this in house anyway?
So, three months later, we need more
time to assess.
We go back to the beginning and in
between, hey, really, we just we need to
build an AI security strategy. So, let's
bring in one of the big fours.
Uh, and then, you know, we'll restart
the process.
And in the meantime, the customer
chatbot is shipped.
So quickly how I built this so I can
actually get to the demo. Um already
mentioned it in using cloud code. Uh
it's an agentic loop um orchestrated um
just within simply within cloud. There's
an research agent and a QC agent. Uh
bunch of system prompts and skills files
that have been res refined over the last
few months. But you know essentially
their task is to go out there and find
evidence for the claims that they're
making. So that evidence can be
contained at GitHub repos, it could be
contained in API documentation, it could
even be in uh user forums um where
people talk about a certain product and
their experience with it. And then based
on the evidence available um the agent
assigns that a confidence uh uh rating.
So you know five out of five is it's
able to extract code samples from GitHub
repos to show how this particular
capability is actually instrumented.
Then we mapped all of those capabilities
to some common uh common AI risk tonomy.
Uh and then all of this comes together
when uh a specific Gen AI system that
somebody's building goes through a
wizard, a series of steps that then make
recommendations about what are the most
appropriate uh set of solutions and then
correspondingly the vendors who are able
to satisfy them.
And then there's some filters that we
added based on early feedback about some
of those other topics. say we're in
PaloAlto, we're in Crowdstrike, they're
doing a lot, they're making investments,
let's look at our existing kind of
strategic investments first before going
to the marketplace. So some of those
types of preferences
um and then the system produces
implementation guidance for um a variety
of teams from GRC to cloud engineering
uh to security architecture and
engineering uh and dev teams if the
choice is made to build some of those
capabilities in house using uh open
source solutions etc.
This is the risk taxonomy. It's um on
GitHub. You could take a look at it, but
it's a essentially a synthesis of LLM
top 10, NIST, AI, RMF, and MITER Atlas.
Each of those three, I think, have
really good components, but uh they
don't tell the whole picture. So, this
was an attempt to kind of uh expand this
and and cover um all of potential
today's uh today's risks in the space.
So, we will
go to
a quick demo.
So we'll put this particular system
through that AI risk modeling wizard.
Now we're calling it adjuster IQ.
Basically claims hit the queue. the
adjuster eqing analyzes gives them
complexity scores uh identifies the
right specialist routing and produces
some uh fraud indicators and then
presents this information to a human
adjuster. So um some of the patterns
that are being used it's being built on
uh using 3.5 sonnet 3.5 via AWS betrock
Amazon Kandra is being used for for rag
uh our orchestration not very
sophisticated direct API calls it's
thanks to doing some tool calling and
memory is session scoped um so that's um
kind of the the key architecture
patterns that are being used.
All right, let me bring up bring up the
tool.
So this is the tool. um you know the net
for starting point as I mentioned was
having a risk taxonomy against which
vendor claims can be uh can be mapped uh
and then evaluated uh against the
evidence. So you know for example let's
look at data disclosure
sensitive data and AI inputs um risks
and we could see kind of the breakdown
then helps us um map the right
commercial solutions against this
capability.
So you know sensitive data and AI inputs
that's a risk input in DLP and redaction
that makes sense right that's a
capability that we need to have to
mitigate that particular risk um you
know there's some guidance that we could
use for a custom uh engineered solution
to do this in house if we want to if we
don't want to go to the marketplace um
or
and by the way uh on the application
layer so through things like SDKs and
APIs there are handful of vendors ers
who are claiming uh that they could do
this. And if we choose to implement this
in the infrastructure layer, so like
some kind of a choke point at the
network or an endpoint agent that's
centrally managed, you know, there are
even more um vendors who are um able to
satisfy that that control.
So I'll bring up kind of quickly what
what that research on any particular
vendor looks like and then we'll put it
all together.
So looking at the vendor card for
Crowdstrike Falcon AID that was through
their PNG acquisition you know this is
we're back at our um risk tonomy.
So for data disclosure, you know, we
could see that they have one capability
and they're doing this at the
application infrastructure layer and we
also know that they're able to deploy
this both at the network choke point
layer and on the endpoint and let's see
what the agent came up with in terms of
uh evidence. Um so that's the kind of
information that u it's able to gather
on these vendors.
Uh not flawlessly. Um there's still even
though there's a lot a lot it's been
refined quite a bit there's a lot of
human QC that goes into um kind of to
manage all of the hallucinations and
context issues that that we discussed
earlier in the day today. Anyway, so let
me close that out and we'll go
and do we have five minutes. Let's see
if we can do a risk assessment of this
adjuster IQ system in five minutes.
So this is the wizard that I was just
talking about. Um right so there's just
a handful of questions that we ask and
these are the kind of questions that we
would ask that we would sit down with a
client in um kind of that use case and
requirements discovery. So what does
this claim adjuster thing can do? It can
be what kind of data um uh does it use?
Internal confidential.
Uh our employees are going to be using
it over the internet. And you can see on
the bottom now we're kind of activating
and surfacing uh various risks that are
associated with the choices that are use
case driven.
We're using AWS Betrock. So that's going
to be manage pass. It's only going to
create new record.
You know, you could see like making an
autonomous actions uh selection results
and quite of a different um inherent
risk profile of this system.
And then
what is the highest level of autonomy?
uh because coding assistants become part
of the attack surface. So what are uh
how are coding assistants being used by
the devs team uh that would introduce um
right so any any anywhere from
autonomous coding agents uh to suggested
to suggesting only coding assistance but
let's go with interactive coding
assistance.
Uh let's see
doing good. I think we'll get there in
the next four minutes.
Okay, so we did our inherent b uh
inherent risk profile. Now we're talking
about architecture patterns and choices
that are being me being used being made
by the team that's building them. So the
kind of things that get discussed
discussed at the uh architecture review
boards um and that would kick off some
kind of a security assessment that may
last who knows how many months in large
enterprises.
So we're in the AWS bedrock again. We're
using rag and traditional databases.
Uh direct API was in the use case. Let's
say we're using servers compute. And you
could see as I'm making these
selections, the uh the risk profile is
changing and we're using the system is
going to give us a chat interface, some
tool calling and let's obviously
document analysis is going to be a big
part.
Okay. Okay. And now we'll get to the
part where um we're able to ask
questions like what security platforms
have you made investment in? Let's look
at those first and see what they can
offer to us against those risks that
we've identified. Uh obviously we're in
um AWS Bedrock. That's going to give us
some some controls. Let's say we're
using we already have Crowdstrike and
Zcaler. Uh that's going to make things a
little bit easier. uh Zcaler has been
adding Genai security capabilities.
Do we um typically buy or build and or
do we have no preference? But let's say
we have we usually buy uh
versus build um implementation layer
preference. So you know a lot of the
vendors are offering really two kind of
implementation paths via SDKs APIs
capabilities that could be provided to
the application development teams versus
things that are centrally deployed and
governed um through uh the
infrastructure. So let's say we're doing
infrastructure.
Um the talk before um the gentleman
mentioned that yeah most of those
solutions are either at the network
layer as as some kind of gateways and
proxies or they're going to be an
endpoints via agents. But let's say we
don't have a preference. So the system
is going to surface vendors who can do
both.
And let's say that we want to um we will
prioritize vendors who provide give us
the most capabilities. So we're leaning
towards platform and let's see what
shows up.
Okay. So what the system is telling us
essentially that you know at the most
critical and high levels uh we have
certain gaps that we need to cover.
Again, that goes back to this risk
profile that gets triggered through uh
through that wizard. And out of our
existing vendor relationships, we're
able to cover eight of those
capabilities. So, let's grab those. And
we have 15 gaps that are remaining.
So, we can drill into each of those and
say that for some of the governance
things, you know, we don't need to buy a
solution. That's, you know, we're
perfectly capable of building an
internal workflow inhouse. So,
select some of those as build.
Accept the rest.
And now this is the short list of uh
vendors that the system is recommending
based on the based on the prior uh kind
of wizard steps that that we went
through. Um so these are the
capabilities and the vendors who who uh
we are confident are able to satisfy
this particular capability.
Uh there's a we could do a combo. So for
aid over the gaps um really the system
is saying we should take a look at five
vendors who are doing each of those is
doing some of those things.
So we can apply
and
get to a page that's really a summary of
all of the things that can be printed
out uh provided to either the sourcing
procurement teams in house or could be
sent to the engineering teams or uh the
development shops uh with you know
either configuration uh guidance for you
know for example the AWS bedrock guard
rails and some of the controls that
they're able to implement or similarly
through uh or um other commercial
solutions or in-house uh built um using
open- source um tools uh and etc. So,
and I looks like I am at time.
I appreciate your watchful watchful eye
and I guess we'll open it to questions
for the next few minutes.
Uh great presentation. Uh but I had a
question about consolidating vendors
versus picking something that is
bestin-class. For example, like Viz is
great at cloud security, but they also
claim to do secret scanning and a bit of
SAS and everything. So I mean how does
your tool or like I mean or what are
your thoughts on picking like a solution
that is like a Swiss army knife does
everything versus picking up something
that is bestin-class. So uh the system
attempts to recommend uh platform if a
platform choice is made but the AI
security landscape is very very
fragmented right. So even the big
companies like PaloAltos and the crowd
strikes whiz is very far from that
category for now they may get there at
some point but they only have a very
small handful of capabilities but uh
even those big platform plays are still
going to give you about 50% of of the
risks that are most relevant. Okay.
>> Hi there. Uh, thanks for going over
this. This is something you and your
organization have built and you guys
maintain this.
>> Yes.
>> Interesting. Um, are you familiar with
Richard Stein and the IT Harvest work
that they do?
>> No.
>> It's like the kaleidoscope of cyber
security vendors.
>> Oh, I've seen it. Yeah. Yeah.
>> The encyclopedia. They publish a book.
It just this seems like it'd be
extremely valuable to them. I don't know
if you guys talk or work together but
>> I've seen it but yeah I have not had any
contact with them.
>> How do you maintain this when such a
high velocity rapidly changing
landscape?
>> So there is a uh via GitHub actions
there's an agentic world workflow that
kicks gets kicked off every evening. So
overnight you know it's about 12 hours
every day. U some subset of these
vendors go through that new research
process again. So every the the goal is
to have every vendor get revisited at
least once a month and then there's a
separate workflow to identify new
players or uh other uh traditional cyber
security vendors who are adding uh AI
security capabilities.
Got time for one more
or zero more. Thank you. All right.
Thank you.